[Applause]
[Music]
we can't hide it here a visual politic
we love Asia and that's partly because
we believe that the world center is
already on this continent but in the
last few decades one country has stood
out of that crowd and that country well
it's China for its huge size and the
speed of which this country is growing
China deserves to be given the chief
role in this super production that is
changing our planet but wait just a
second let's not rush into this whole
thing
China it's certainly not perfect indeed
the country had some pretty major
problems on the 23rd of may 2017 Moody's
one of the three agencies in charge of
rating the solvency and risk of
financial products downgraded the rating
of China's debt and this is the first
reduction Moody's has made on China's
debt in 27 years yeah okay now I know
you're thinking leadings really rating
agencies in general and they rarely seem
to get it right and yeah while that is
true it is also one of the only things
that we have to judge this sort of thing
confessors still overwhelmingly rely on
Standard and Poor's Moody's and Fitch
when deciding whether to buy bonds the
three issue more than 95% of global bond
ratings the thing is dear viewers China
has faced two major threats in the last
few years less growth and much much more
debt in fact this has even led to an
important question can China go bankrupt
[Music]
China's great growth if we had a sign
machine and the opportunities travel
bags mouths China the country we would
find would be completely different to
the one that we find today there
wouldn't be any skyscrapers anymore in
fact there really wouldn't be much of
anything in the nineteen seventies China
was a mainly agricultural country and it
was extremely poor but a few years after
Mao had died a man known as dong Jinping
came to power and he realized that
communism well it really hadn't worked
it's all he immediately put into
practice a set of measures that that
would change China forever these reforms
and the change that China has gone
through since they're actually going to
be the subject of an upcoming visual
politic videos so please don't forget to
subscribe to this channel right now all
right done that
well that's carry-on so now it's
important to remember something done
jumping was a turning point for China
since then China has undergone the
greatest economical revolution in the
history of mankind in the last three
decades China has managed to take five
hundred million people out of poverty
and to become the largest industrial and
trading power on the planet in other
words if we ask any Chinese person
without his or her living standards the
answer will be as it and now is
infinitely better than it was before
and please don't get me wrong there is
still a lot of poverty in China but
compared to how it was it's a whole lot
better today
but as I was saying earlier it's
certainly not all roses and there are
some serious clouds on there risin a
system addicted to debt are they quick
look at this chart which shows what
happens to Chinese debt in the last few
years as you can see it goes up and up
burns up and I mean well that's a
seriously speed line on the other hand
the closely of what has happened to
Chinese economic groups as you can see
well this chart it's headed in the
opposite direction so in other words in
China the economy is declining and the
debt won't stop rising
[Music]
look in gross terms the Chinese debt as
multiplying by four since 2007 the
Chinese debt now equals more than 260
percent of the GDP and many analysts
consider this number to be especially
high for a country that is yet to become
one of the richest in the world well
most of the debt is actually the
responsibility of Chinese companies well
the thing is there is a silver lining
but there is also a significant negative
side and that is that all this
international expansion needs money and
swell a great deal of it and while much
of the debt has financed the expansion
of Chinese companies they have also paid
well for this kind of nonsense
throughout China there are hundreds of
cities that have almost everything one
needs from modern urban lifestyle
high-rise apartment complexes developed
waterfronts skyscrapers and even public
art everything that is except one major
factor people
so you get an idea of the size of all
that has been built in China in the last
few years pay attention to the following
number in just three years China is used
more concrete than the United States
used in the entire 20th century and as I
said everything absolutely everything
has been paid for with yes so now we
come to a really important what the hell
has happened in this country to cause it
to get into quite so much debt the
Chinese government's forward flight the
last few decades if you could say that
Chinese people were good at one thing
well it would be saving money this is
especially true of the oldest Chinese
citizens they work and they save and
well that is pretty much all they do so
thanks to all of that effort
China has high investment rates but
don't be fooled what has happened in the
last few years having nothing to do with
it in order to know what happens we need
to go back to 2008 at that time all
developed countries were going through a
major financial crisis and you can
probably imagine how this affected
China's exports which are the engine
that keeps driving China forward the
traces but at that time the Chinese
government was terrified that the
country would be affected by the
international crisis so in order to
prevent it they came up with an idea the
economic system had to be transformed
and they had to bet on domestic demand
and when it comes to in the mouth of a
politician that domestic demand thing
almost always means they are planning to
start overspending and salome that's
exactly what Beijing did
in 2008 the Chinese government started a
colossal program of extra public
spending of four trillion UN about six
hundred billion dollars meant to be used
for building all kinds of infrastructure
high-speed trains Underground trains
highways houses offices etc ah they went
further than that the Chinese
government's thoughts that government
overspending wasn't enough so they had
to encourage the companies to do the
same so the question was how could they
do that well they decided to use a
traditional remedy in 2008 China also
started one of the most expansive
monetary policies ever known the
authorities lowered interest rates and
banks gave money loans to everyone who
asked for them they practically
established an open bar of cheap loans
in three years the price of housing with
an average of 2.4 times more expensive
so an apartment which cost $100,000
three years before would now be worth
two hundred and forty thousand dollars
and so what was the result of all of
this well companies started to make all
kinds of investments they built ghost
towns bought out companies all over the
world and engaged in all kinds of
projects they took on whatever crazy
risky projects they felt like after all
the central bank was pretty much giving
money away over production in key
industries are damaging both China's
economic sustainability and foreign
trade relations obviously many of these
projects have never been profitable so
the companies can't give the money back
so what do they do then
well they simply ask for new loans to
pay back the old one than the snobol
kept rolling and getting bigger and
bigger and this is how the Chinese
economy became addicted to debt and now
I've probably got an idea of what you're
thinking stupid private companies right
well not exactly more than half of the
bank debt in China consists of loans
from state-owned banks to state-owned
enterprises and wait just a second
because there is so much more
[Music]
Chinese banks a weapon of mass
destruction
we've already seen how China is
currently going through a debt overdose
but as if this wasn't enough there is
another danger hiding in the bushes back
in the shadows nice face certain
limitations on the amount of money they
can load but Chinese banks have managed
to skip these controls and in way these
banks have just copied what American
banks were doing with them mortgages let
me explain instead of just giving loans
they set up off balance companies that
issued the debt of the banks then bought
and lien surprised surprised when you
look at the bank's accounts are not
listed as loans that are rather as other
investments it's actually a pretty small
workaround right well it is estimated
the Chinese banks have hidden more than
two trillion dollars and it has a
straightforward consequence Chinese
banks can be way less solvent than their
official numbers might indicate and
besides much of this debt is opaque so
the actual Chinese debt could be much
much higher the fast spread of
off-balance activities in Bank
investment actually means a risk of
hidden loans which could threaten
China's financial security xiangfu lien
ex-president of China's Banking
Regulatory Commission and wait because
there's more
the growing number of non-bank financial
firms also market their own wealth
management products and invest the money
with little disclosure of where the
money goes that's right in the last few
years those companies which get money
from people to make investments that are
risky and opaque have become more and
more popular and twelve why is that well
it's obviously because they're going to
get higher rates of return with those
investments the thing is that this
craving for loans has caused quite a bit
of indigestion this is a risk the
government has admitted and it has tried
to limit company loans but since there
are a lot of unsold ghost towns empty
houses and bankrupt real estate agencies
the government has told the banks in the
last few years to give away loans as if
there was no tomorrow because well the
family debt level is still so low that
economists note that China's mortgage
loans increased by thirty five percent
in 2016 and now this view you might be
beginning to see why some analysts are
warning that if they don't stop this
dead vortex China could become a new
Japan a country that has been in crisis
since the 1980s and there is still more
because now we know why she Jinping and
China need globalization quite so much
their accompanying a need for a market
to deal with all of the debt that they
have issued but not everything is all
doom and gloom and the future well it's
still to come in China the savings rates
are still high high enough for foreign
capital to arrive in the country
but there is a risk and Moody's has
given the first warning now it's the
time for the government to start working
to make reforms and now well we'd love
to know your thoughts you can tell us
what you think in this survey as well as
in the comments below this video what do
you think will happen in China do you
think that stagnation will turn it into
a new Japan or do you think they'll be
new reforms which will open China even
more to the west well I do really hope
that you enjoyed their video and if you
did please do hit that like button and
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
already to a new videos are uploaded
every Monday and every Thursday and do
not forget to check out our threatens at
the weekend to the media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
are not mine and as always I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
you